Ron  Desantis is threatening to prosecute TV station
that air pro choice ads that he doesn't like
as if the First Amendment doesn't apply to him
first and most importantly
let's watch the ad that he's trying to ban
my first thought was am I gonna be able to see my daughter again
the doctors knew if I did not in my pregnancy
I would lose my baby I would lose my life
and my daughter would lose her mom
Florida has now banned abortion
even in cases like mine amendment for is gonna protect women like me
we have to vote yes the ad is encouraging voters to vote for amendment for
which would untried abortion rights into the state constitution
and Republicans know that abortion access is overwhelmingly popular
even among Republicans so they don't like ballot initiatives
because they generally need to keep the issue of abortion out of voters hands
every time abortion has been on the ballot
even in red states voters have come out and said that they want abortion access
so Desantis is doing everything possible to try to get in the way
he's spending taxpayer dollars to fight the amendment
he is sending out election police to interrogate and intimidate residents
and apparently now
he is threatening to prosecute TV stations
that run ads to promote the amendment
the letter um
claims that the ad spreads false
dangerous information
because Florida's six week abortion ban actually does not pose any health risks
to women I
oh my god
forcing women to carry unwanted pregnancies is incredibly dangerous
maternal mortality in abortion ban states is skyrocketing
see what the letter is saying is no
actually see
we have these exceptions for
to save the life of the woman or if she's at serious risk of substantial
irreversible physical impairment
as I and physicians all over the country have explained
is you can't legislate on healthcare
you can't say well
you can treat someone if they're on
you know if it's to save their life
it's like what
what point is that do we need to wait until women go into organ failure
do we need to wait until they go into septic shock
do we have to try organ transplants first
like this doesn't make any sense
and in Florida if a doctor gets it wrong
they face five years in prison
physicians are understandably reluctant to provide care in the state of Florida
because they are risking prosecution
and having the state disagree with their medical judgment
the state basically saying well
she wasn't sick enough yet to qualify for the exception
every time I explain this
I'm like this is so insane
what really makes me wanna just send myself to the moon is in this letter
they're like you know
because of your ad women may believe that treatments are available in Florida
so they might travel out of state and not get care here
oh my god
you guys are threatening physicians with five years in prison
if they provide an abortion that you don't like
you are the reason that Florida residents are in danger
their life is in danger and that they are being sent out of state for care
before I digress even further
um in the United States
we have something called the First Amendment
the government doesn't get to pick and choose
and regulate speech it doesn't like
Rhonda Santos doesn't get to threaten to prosecute TV stations
for running ads he doesn't like
Republican efforts to keep the issue of abortion out of voters hands
and doing things like this
threatening to prosecute um
speech that it doesn't like
all of this is emblematic of how attacks on abortion are attacks on democracy
if you wanna learn more about this
I cannot recommend Jessica Valentie enough
and her new book is out on abortion
I highly recommend getting it
there's so much more I could say about this
um but for now
let me know what questions that you have
I'm the feminist lawyer follow me if you enjoy being miserable